hey chess friends national master james
cantona here with chess.com and today
i'm going to give you four tips
to improving your chest openings today
now i made this video with beginners in
mind
so if you're more of an experienced
player it's always good to refresh
your memory on opening principles now
let's get into today
my first tip when playing the opening is
to control the center of the board
now what do i mean by the center of the
board i'm talking about four
special squares let's look at them e4 d4
e5 and d5 very important the whole game
revolves around the center of the board
here
and you want to make sure you put your
pieces in the center of the board let's
take a look
let's say we play a move like knight to
f3 and black may be responding with d5
putting a pawn
in the center of the board here but it's
very nice to have our pieces here if we
put a knight in the center
check this out guys look at how many
squares we have one two three
four five six seven eight squares from
the center
of the board that's why it's very
important to put it in the center it
gives you options
flexibility and it's a very strong piece
in the center of the board all of your
pieces will be like that
now let's actually check and see what
happens on what happens if we put it on
the edge of the board
this is a big beginner mistake that many
players do actually
and the problem here is that they have a
saying the knight on the rim
is grim and it's not good to be able to
do that because we cutting our squares
off
by half literally four squares
are gone from our knight because we
moved it to the edge of the board
and this is why it's not good let's say
we put it on maybe g5
g5 still cuts off some squares from our
knight it was having eight squares
now having one two three four five six
squares here
when it gets closer to the edge of the
board and this is why you want to put
your knights
and your pieces in the center of the
board and now let's take a look at some
pawn moves to help you control the
center of the board
here we go e4 great move by white here
putting a pawn in the center of the
board here one of the four squares in
the center
we place our pawn on e4 and black plays
a very strange move which is h5
or even a5 these are very strange moves
now let me ask you a question
does this move actually do anything for
the center
well the answer there is absolutely not
it doesn't do anything for the center
here
so we're going to put our second pawn
the d-pawn in the center of the board
as we now have full control over the
center so you see the e pawn actually
has influence in controlling the d5
square
same with the deeper d4 pawn having
control and influence over the e5 square
and we have pawns on the e and d squares
e4 and d4 squares
having the entire sensor to ourselves
here
now if you are a beginner it's very
great to start putting your pawns in the
center by starting with either the e
pawn
or the d-pawn and hopefully in a perfect
world you would have both of them
but it's good to push one or the other
one now we're gonna move on to tip
number two
tip number two is very important here
because of course even a lot of
intermediate players
forget to do this and that's a great
thing because if they forget it that
means you'll be able to beat them
so tip number two is actually
development of
your pieces one of your main goals of
the opening is to get your guys out so
they can make a difference that's called
development
what actually is development well
development is getting the guys
off the back rank getting them off of
the first or the eighth rank
all of them maybe the rooks can stay
there on the eighth or the first rank
for a while
but you definitely have to get the
knights the bishop the queens
of course the king is going to stay safe
in castle somewhere
which we'll talk about later but here
you have to make sure you get the pieces
off the back rank and that's what
development is
so if you ever hear the term develop or
development that means you should put
your pieces on the best squares and get
them off the back rank
so the best thing for you to do is to
try to develop your pieces in a way that
your whole army has open lines and
diagonals to help you control the center
let's take a look at that here it is we
have a e4 and
knight f6 so of course developing but
also attacking the pawn type
kind of a strange move but we're going
to keep moving d4 here
and then knight to g8 knight's just
going back and then knight to f3
we're going to just develop our pieces
guys and we're going to play knight to
c3 defending this pawn this time
and this knight is just moving back and
forth very strange but you guys will see
it in your own games believe it or not
knight to g8 and bishop to c4 here as
you see look at the bishop
and the knights and the pawns all
influencing the center
this is what they call sometimes the
perfect position in a way
as we're going to develop our next piece
to f4 look at the bishop here
developing attacking the center helping
the knights and the pawns all
harmoniously
as the team is all working together to
control the center very nice diagonals
for the bishops here
the knights are helping in short range
here the pawns are helping look at all
the arrows
harmoniously working together like this
knight to ga
and then queen to e2 why moving our
queen well you do want to move your
queen off of the back rank
to connect the rooks if you can connect
the rooks then you have completed your
development so after knight to f6
there's a castle by white
now the rooks are talking to each other
they can see each other they're
definitely happy rooks here and they're
connected
after knight to g1 now we want to
centralize all of our pieces
every single one everything revolves
around the center
and after rook a to d1 knight to f6 and
rook h to e1 we have reached our
dream position in a way here the pieces
are all developed they're not blocking
each other
and everything is working harmoniously
together guys and this is
development and what you should strive
for in your own games tip number three
is about
king safety keeping the king safe and
this is why
we should castle our king or worry about
our king safety more than anything else
even if you follow the first two steps
of controlling the center and developing
our pieces
if you get checkmated it doesn't really
matter so you do have to make sure that
your king safety is 100
important there's two sides we can
castle to king side or queen side
it does depend on what kind of position
you're going for or how fast you
actually develop your pieces
but let's see what happens here after d
take c3 a6 very strange move
not doing anything for the center not
worrying about king safety
but nevertheless we still have chess to
play bishop to f4 we're developing a
piece
putting it in the center of course we
don't want to go here but we are
developing a piece
h6 which is a very another strange move
here then we get our queen off of the
back rank
preparing to castle queenside and after
b6
there's a bishop to d3 move here so it's
a very nice move it actually
does a lot with this diagonal and we can
actually castle to
both sides of the board here which is
very flexible
and we can go either way here it's
pretty nice depending on what
kind of position you have but let's see
what black does rook a7
kind of a very very very weird move here
you should be developing
your pieces as usual and get castle but
white says hey i'm going to castle
queenside
i have an extra pawn over here that can
help me with my defense and my rooks are
now going to centralize
where the king is in the center of the
board king safety
is very important and you should never
keep your king in the center before
doing other operations
this is why you should develop your
pieces and if we look at black's pieces
we haven't done much development at all
besides the rook on a7
it does almost the same thing as the
rook on a8 so we really didn't do
anything here
now after castle's queen side black can
play a move like maybe rook to g8 which
is another
bad move here but this now we're going
to take advantage of it because we have
castle
white has developed the pieces here and
now we're going to make a nice move not
only
do we put our pieces in the center of
the board just like we looked at before
with our perfect position
and putting the pieces and centralizing
them in the center of the board
this rook is now checking the king
asking him what are you going to do now
are you going to play something like
bishop e7
or bishop e6 and if bishop to e6 then we
have
knight to d4 attacking the bishop once
again and black is
under fire already this is not the
position you're looking for at all
the king is very unsafe and the rook is
it is at a moment's notice going to
crash through in this position
and checkmate is almost imminent tip
number four is to prevent
our opponent from doing steps one
through three
and that would be stopping them from
controlling the center stopping them
from developing
and also trying to stop them from
castling in a timely manner let's
actually take a look at an example here
we have e4 and g6 so e4 being a strong
move here putting a pawn in the center
as we've seen before
and black playing sort of an off-center
move now let's see what happens we play
d4
he's going to give us the entire center
we're going to take the entire center
here
e4 and d4 as we've seen before pawns are
looking great on these squares
and controlling the other ones right in
front of them pretty nice now
after that we have knight to f6
attacking our e4 pawn
we don't want to give him this pawn for
free at all so we're actually going to
develop
at the same time defending our pawn on
e4 black now plays e6 here says i might
kill a bishop here
and just maybe hopefully you know anchor
a pawn here and be able to put something
in the center
white plays knight to f3 just developing
to the center of the board
as we should as this is something we
know how to do already
in bishop e7 we want to prevent
development castling
and our opponent from having a big
center after bishop b7 we'll look at
this very sweet
and strong move here bishop to h6 now
stopping the king from castling
you can't castle into or through check
so it won't allow me i can't even put
the king there
because it's a rule that you can't
castle through check
so i'm actually have to go through the
check here to castle and i can't castle
when i'm in check as well so bishop h6
cuts off the king so that i cannot
castle so black says okay i can't castle
we're going to do something else
b6 to try to develop on the other side
of the board and white says bishop to
c4 stopping d5 just a little bit more
still can be played
but probably not the best move after
bishop to c4
knight to c6 we're just going to keep
developing our pieces says black
white says queen to e2 as we have moved
our our minor pieces first the knights
and the bishops
then we're going to move our queen as we
should we shouldn't be moving our queen
out early as we learned
before and after queen e2 there's bishop
to b7 as black is trying to catch up
and try to castle maybe queenside
because i can't go king side because
we've prevented him
from doing so after bishop to b7 there's
castles queen side
we also just as well could have casted
king side as well but castle queenside
is very nice in this position
and black plays a6 just trying to figure
out what to do
making more moves here maybe a move like
b5 could happen and after a6
it's time to open up the position for us
because we are now developed
we want to stop d5 from ever happening
and we want to take full control over
the center and really restrict white's
pieces and the development
and the king hopefully we can keep it in
the center for as long as possible let's
see what happens
d5 very strong move attacking this
knight and this pawn
and this pawn says i've had enough of
that e takes d5 i'm going to get rid of
it
but we have a back up here e takes d5
once again and now we've opened up this
line to the king here
looking very bad knight goes back to b8
and we have developed a piste
and now we've undeveloped a piece as
black which is not very very bad
we're very very long away from castling
we're very far from castling it's not
fun to be black here
and after rook hce1 we've centralized
our pieces
and there's no space for black here we
can't move anything
black tries to make a move here and try
to attack a pawn
to do literally something and we have
this nice move here
d6 as this game is virtually over here
as you can't move your king you can't
move this bishop you can't move
virtually
anything and this is actually what you
want to have in your own games
is preventing your opponents from
developing controlling the center
and castling one final thought before we
wrap things up if you're a beginner and
you want to get better at chess openings
there's no need to memorize opening
lines like crazy
it's much better for you to understand
the principles behind good openings
because that way you'll always know what
to do even if your opponent plays a
weird move
so keep these four tips in mind and i'm
sure that you improve very very fast
if you want to learn more about chess
openings click the link in the
description below the video
and take a lesson on chess.com also
don't forget to like the video
subscribe to our channel and let me know
in the comments what topic you like
me to talk about next i'm national
master james canty iii here with
chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video